- We are here with the Real Housewives,
Teresa, Luann, Ramona, Kenya and Cynthia.
(audience cheers and applauds)
So, okay, these ladies have become known
as some of the most famous
Real Housewives on TV,
but how well do they, or I,
I probably am going to be
great at this, Cynthia.
How well do they know TV's most popular,
fictitious housewives.
It's time to find out with a game called
"Playing Housewives."
(audience cheers and applauds)
(upbeat music)
We have our teams, it looks
like we called each other
- Yes.
- Because red and pink go well together.
- Oh yeah!
- It's me and Cynthia
versus Teresa and Luann,
versus Ramona and Kenya.
(audience applauds)
Which y'all kinda match too.
- Yeah we do.
- Dear Lord may we call upon your grace
for some assistance.
- [Announcer God] Well,
hello Kelly, sure thing,
I'm happy to help as long
as none of you have sinned,
I'm just playing, I'm just
playing, I see everything.
You all sinners, you all sinners.
(laughs)
- [Announcer God] We'll do
confessions after the show.
- We're trying our best God.
- [Announcer God] That's
right, that's right.
All right, now here's how the game works.
Now I'll give you a clue that
involves a famous housewife
from a great American television show.
And the first person who
knows the name of the show,
you're going to hit your buzzer.
Now, if you're right, you get
a point, but if you're wrong,
the other teams can steal
and that's worth two points.
- Ooh! Okay!
- [Announcer God] So don't
get too confident down there,
which I realize is a
big ask for this group.
(women laugh)
- [Announcer God] I did say
big ask. Okay, here we go.
(woman laughs)
- Hey you know the other's fine too.
- [Announcer God] That's right, girl.
All right, here we go, that's the buzzer.
- If you know it you
have to hit the button.
- [Announcer God] You got it.
That's right. Okay. You ready?
Here's your first one.
- Okay.
- [Announcer God] Carol had six kids.
(buzzer dings)
- Oh!
- I know it!
[Ramona] (hits buzzer
multiple times) I know it!
- I won I got excited. I know the answer.
(audience laughs)
- Carol had six kids and she is done.
- No you're reading a teleprompter.
- [Cynthia] You have to
listen to the whole question.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay, oh wait,
yeah, we should shut this off.
- Yeah you can't do this.
- She can go. Carol had six kids,
I think we all know who it is. Okay.
- Yeah. The Brady Bunch
- The Brady Bunch
(buzzer dings)
- [Announcer God] Good
News, it is The Brady Bunch.
- But y'all gotta know, I can read it.
I don't want to be the cheater.
- [Kelly] But everybody
knew Carol had six kids,
so you got that one.
- [Announcer God] I
have lost total control
of this game show.
(women laugh)
- Okay, okay, okay, all
right God we're ready.
- [Announcer God] There's six
of y'all, there's six of y'all
but only two that's in the lead right now.
So here we go.
(women laugh)
Here's your next one.
Wheezy and her husband George.
(buzzer dings)
- The Jefferson's
- I hit it first!
- She hit it first.
- I hit it first.
(buzzer dings)
- [Announcer God] It is The Jefferson's.
That's right.
- I hit the button!
- I hit the button first!
- No, we did!
(overlapping arguments)
- Was I not saved first?
- But we both had to hit it.
- Our button was not working, God.
- We got another two points.
- [Kelly] That's two,
God, I'm just saying.
Just, the buttons need to work
because Cynthia hit the button.
- I did.
- She didn't hit it until after me though.
- All right, next question!
- [Announcer God] Alright now listen.
(overlapping arguments)
I command you.
I command you, I command
you all to shut up.
(audience laughs)
And the winner so far is nobody,
because this is a disaster.
(women laugh)
And it's exactly what
I thought it would be.
(audience laughs)
Because I can see all.
- [Kelly] I'm so competitive, I love this.
- [Announcer God] All right,
here is the next question.
- Okay.
- [Announcer God] And I'm
praying that the buzzer works
on this one.
- Okay.
- [Announcer God] This housewife
might have been a mother,
but she was probably better
known as Aunt Viv on what show?
(slapping of the buzzer)
- Ah! Fresh Prince of Bel Air!
(buzzer dings)
(audience applauds)
- [Announcer God] It is The
Fresh Prince of Bel Air!
- [Kelly] You're incredible.
(women cheer)
I'm just saying, Kenya is incredible!
- [Announcer God] Now
Kenya for a bonus point,
can you do the Carlton dance?
- Oh yeah!
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- [Announcer God] That's
what I'm talking about!
Go ahead and well give 'em
another point, sure why not.
(buzzer dings)
- Oh my god!
- [Announcer God] We're
just making things up.
- [Kelly] Kenya is a beast.
- [Announcer God] There you
go. That's a bonus point
for doing the Carlton.
- I'm trying, I'm trying.
I think we're moving our thing.
- [Announcer God] Here's
your next question.
- Okay, here we go, here we go.
- [Announcer God] This housewife
was a bit two dimensional,
but made up for it with
four feet of blue hair
on top of her head in what show?
(buzzer slapping)
- The Simpson's!
(buzzer dings)
- [Announcer God] It was The Simpson's!
(women and audience cheer)
- Wow you're good!
- Yes!
- Okay. Okay.
This is my show.
And I say Kenya's kicked off.
(women laugh)
- [Cynthia] Yes kick her off!
- This is so amazing.
- And she said she
wouldn't be good at this!
- You know here's the thing.
I'm actually, I'm so proud of you Kenya.
Oh my God, okay, keep going God.
- [Announcer God] Well, look
at this Ramona and Kenya,
you in the lead.
That's all I know.
Okay, so let's hear it.
Let's hear it for you two.
(audience applauds)
All right, this is what I'm talking about.
(Audience applauds)
Here's your next question.
The housewife in this very macabre family
was related only by blood to
Uncle Fester on what show?
- Addams Family! Addams Family!
- [Announcer God] It was
(buzzer dings)
the Addams Family!
- We got it! We got it! We got it!
Oh what's up Kenya, what's
up Kenya. What's up!
(conversations overlap)
- How many questions are there?
- [Announcer God] There's
as many questions as I say.
(women laugh)
Creepy cooky, mysterious and spooky.
- Okay, okay.
(air horn blasts)
- [Announcer God] Oh, and it's
time for our final question.
- Okay
- But we won.
- No!
- [Announcer God] And this
one is worth 50,000 points.
(women cheer)
(audience applauds)
- Okay.
- Let's focus.
- [Announcer God] This housewive's husband
famously said her name
before announcing "I'm home"
on what show?
- Honey, I'm home.
- Oh, oh, oh, the late night Honeymooners.
(buzzer buzzes)
- [Announcer God] It is
not The Honeymooners.
- Wait...
(buzzer dings)
- It's the girl... sexy...
- That's The Honeymooners.
- [Announcer God] No, that's not it.
- Ralph?
- Peggy I'm home!
The Bundy... no what is it called?
(audience cheers)
(buzzer buzzes)
Married with Children!
- [Announcer God] I'm
sorry, that's not correct.
We was looking for I Love Lucy.
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
Lucy I'm home!
- [Announcer God] That
sound means that your time
on this planet has come to an end.
I'm just playing, the game's over,
and the winner is of
course, Ramona and Kenya.
You have done it!
(Audience cheers and applauds)
- Okay, how did I not get I love Lucy?
(women laugh)
- And because they know
their housewives best,
Ramona and Kenya will
have their photos hung
on the Blake Sheldon Wall of Champions.
(women cheer)
- Oh my god that's so exciting!
(women and audience cheer)
- It's not that exciting Ramona!
- It is to me!